this episode is brought to you by ridge
wallet
[Music]
what's up guys jared here if you've
checked twitter or turned on the news
recently you might have noticed a theme
we are seeing president trump's odds of
reelection starting to dwindle quite
significantly and this will be over by
by january one way the other day so from
the consumer side
very very strong and that's really a
driver of the overall
profit economic forecast how far will
covet spread
who's going to win the election when
will the economy crash
there's no shortage of people who claim
to have hacked the future
in the 70s people claim they could
predict the stock market based on who
won the super bowl and you don't need to
think that far back to remember this
republicans are not going to win this
next election or this that the
coronavirus will follow the same path
and go away with the arrival of warmer
weather in the summer or who can forget
jim cramer with this doozy
should i be worried about bear stearns
in terms of liquidity and get my money
out there
no no no right before 2008's financial
crash
it was the worst day on wall street
since the crash of 1987.
we're surrounded by very bad predictions
whether they're from your uncle
teachers news personalities even people
with fancy degrees
so what can you do to not fall for the
snake oil of charming political punditry
and who can you believe
welcome to this wisecrack edition on
predictions what do they know do they
know things
let's find out but before we continue i
want to give a shout out to our sponsors
over at
ridge the ridge is a light and sleek
wallet that is designed to help you get
rid of your old lumpy leather wallet
the ridge wallet is the last wallet you
may ever need since each one is made
from extremely durable materials
like carbon fiber burnt titanium and
aluminum
in fact they're so durable that each
wallet comes with a lifetime warranty
it holds up to 12 cards and still has
room for cash
and the best part is that it's made with
rfid blocking technology
so you're protected from digital pick
pockets i love that it's just
so slim and i don't have to go out with
awkward dad pockets every time i want to
go to the store
it also looks really stylish and get
your own wallet in over 30 different
colors and styles
right now you can get your own ridge
wallet for 10 off by going to ridge.com
wisecrack and using the code wisecrack
at checkout
and now back to the show let me start by
introducing you to philip tetlock
a psychologist who has spent much of his
career studying political forecasting
over 20 years he tracked 80 000
predictions made by almost 300 people
all of whom made a living offering
insights into the future of politics and
the economy
and what he found was well pretty
terrible
tedluck measured the predictions that
could be put on some kind of scale like
will there be more of something
less of something or will it stay the
same today's version of these
predictions might sound like
will the war in syria get better worsen
or stay the same
one might also predict if support for
donald trump or joe biden respectively
will
increase decrease or again stay the same
you might expect someone with a
political science background to excel
here armed with facts
they could confidently forecast what's
going to happen in syria
i on the other hand might wildly guess a
b or
c but here's the thing according to
tetlock i'd probably
beat most of the experts that's right
tetlock's professional predictors of the
world were generally
less accurate than random chance or
monkeys throwing darts
or jared bauer wildly guessing on a
history exam
however you want to think about it so
screw the experts
well not quite tetlock is quick to point
out that while people have taken his
study to mean that there are no
trustworthy experts
that's not the case they're just a small
minority
but it gets worse tedlock found one
specific kind of
expert among his study the bold
predictors
people who have a theory of how the
world works are completely sure of that
theory and make
daring big predictions tetlock calls
these people hedgehogs and to put it
bluntly
they're the worst i want nachos and
buffalo wings oh and guac
funny word isn't it let's look at
political commentator and famous
hedgehog bill crystal
a man who makes his living writing and
talking about the news
he predicted iraq would be a two-month
war this is going to
and that barack obama would not win a
single primary over hillary clinton
in 2015 amidst the republican campaigns
he had proclaimed
peak trump no less than 11 times and
bill crystal despite all of this
has a thriving career on cable news
crystal's bad predictions aren't an
ideological issue
tetlock found bold predicting hedgehogs
equally on the left
and the right but get ready a storm is
coming though they tended towards the
more extreme ends of each spectrum
and it's not just that crystal and
people like him are dumb dumbs on tv who
don't know anything
tetlock found as a hedgehog's knowledge
increases about a specific topic
their prediction accuracy worsens from
here we can immediately understand the
problem about some of the bolder covid
predictions
that it would definitely fizzle out by
april and that outbreak will reach its
highest point
in the second week of april or that
hydroxychloroquine was a wonder drug
before we all had the data
a very powerful drug these so-called
experts stand in stark contrast to the
people we should
actually be listening to tedlock's other
kind of expert is a lot less interesting
to listen to than hedgehogs like jim
cramer or bill crystal
tetlock calls them foxes they were
experts who would hem and haw about the
future
considering a wide variety of data
points and perspectives
good morning chidi blueberry muffin for
you uh i don't know maybe i can't decide
you're right there mate okay i've made
my decision
i want to start crying they're not
exactly crystal balls but they have a
better track record than the hedgehogs
unlike hedgehogs they've become more
accurate as they accumulate more
knowledge
but most of the time foxes don't exactly
make for entertaining cable news guests
after all what's more fun an expert
predicting a landslide election that
will forever change the nation
or someone who likes to dive into the
countless variables and uncertainty
before just shrugging their shoulders
and declaring that there's not enough
data but what about covid predictions
i'm not talking about pundits on cnn i'm
talking about the scientists
it seems that even listening to them
they're always changing their minds
about how many people will get sick or
die
are these just talking heads making big
bold predictions with absolutely no
scrutiny
not quite obviously holding people
accountable for
they were wrong about is fine and good
but to understand why coveted
predictions are always changing
and for good reason i want to talk about
the weather
48 degrees in the upper northwest and
38 degrees in the middle east we're
actually very good at predicting the
weather
so let's talk about it with a little bit
of a dumbed-down model generally if
there's a 90
chance of rain for a specific area it
will rain 9 times out of 10
and won't rain 1 out of 10 times and
because meteorologists are constantly
making predictions we can scrutinize
their track record
and they can improve upon it things get
more complicated when you forecast for
large areas
like when part of a city has a 100
chance of rain and the other half has a
40
chance these probabilities will often
get mushed together but again
we're working with the very basic unit
of forecasting the important thing for
weather predicting is that it relies on
a model of how the weather works
a model is like your kindergarten arts
and crafts project
a smaller more manageable representation
of a much bigger and complicated reality
in the case of a meteorologist their
model might include wind patterns and
pressure fronts and how these interact
to figure out how likely it is that a
storm system will ruin my dog pageant
importantly weather models and all
models rely on assumptions
models make assumptions about which
variables matter and prioritize them
over others to figure out a very
specific outcome
weather predictions assume for instance
that youtube's trending videos won't
influence a storm front
and for good reason covid models do the
same for example they might be less
interested in the variable how many
wisecrack subscribers a state has and
more interested in the percentage of
people who are social distancing
predicting rain is a yes or no outcome
that can be given a specific probability
however when it comes to covid where the
total number of cases can be anywhere
from zero to approximately eight billion
it's a little less helpful and a lot
harder to say there is a one billionth
of a percent chance that exactly 37
people will get infected
instead epidemiologists use confidence
intervals which is a fancy way of saying
i'm 95 confident the amount of new cases
will be between this number
and that number but like the weather
there's also the understanding that the
real number could fall outside that
range five percent of the time
and importantly that number range rests
on a lot of assumptions
assumptions about how infectious the
disease is the percentage of infections
mass usage could decrease
how many states will enter lockdown how
well will they enforce it will people in
florida start having coveted parties to
spread the disease
unsurprisingly getting every assumption
right is a pretty herculean task
especially when talking about finicky
humans as statistician george e box
writes
all models are wrong the practical
question is how wrong do they have to be
to not be useful
and unlike our weather system disease
outbreaks involve people who can be
influenced by your prediction
and completely upend your assumptions if
your model says
this will all be over next week with the
assumption that everyone will stay
indoors
my friends and i might declare an early
victory and resume our normal practice
of licking the fresh produce at whole
foods
don't do this you know something that
undermines the model's assumptions
hypotheticals aside one example of
assumptions gone wrong can be seen
in the much reported prediction in april
that coronavirus deaths would virtually
stop in the summer this model put out by
the institute for health metrics and
evaluation
made one assumption that was lambasted
by other public health experts
that the united states curve of cases
would resemble that of countries like
china and italy
in some ways this is exactly what
modeling is about condensing the
complicated information into a graspable
proxy
but it also rests on the assumption that
the state and federal governments would
act in a comparable way to other
governments
that people would wear masks in a
similar fashion etc and as you may have
guessed america doesn't act like other
countries i don't mean to compare the
imhe here to hedgehogs on the news
though
making wrong assumptions shouldn't cast
someone into prediction hell
unless they do so time after time
without ever pausing for reflection
unfortunately this is what some media
outlets will have you believe
that changing a prediction is a sign of
an intellectual failure
for instance a model from imperial
college london projected that without
drastic interventions more than half a
million britons would die from covet 19.
later the scientists who led the
modeling team said he expected deaths in
the uk to top out at twenty thousand the
fatalities would be probably unlikely to
exceed about twenty thousand
with with a effectively a lockdown this
caused one reporter to call it a
remarkable turn on twitter while the
daily mail ran a story on the
scientist's patchy record
and the federalist declared that he just
walked back the apocalyptic prediction
but of course there was no changing
course as the imperial college model
predicted multiple outcomes based on
different assumptions
in this case the scary number was always
the government does nothing assumption
and the 20 000 dead was under the
drastic government intervention
assumption
and of course any models imperial
college or otherwise
should change their estimates as more
data pours in about transmission rate of
the disease
about if reinfection is possible and so
on and here is the mark of a good
predictor
and someone who likely isn't as
entertaining on tv
a person who understands their
assumptions about how they might
possibly go wrong
it's also why you should listen to data
scientists about coveted numbers even
after they allegedly change their minds
even the current imhe prediction tool
which is publicly available
lets you tweak for certain assumptions
like the easing of lockdowns or
widespread mass usage
a similar problem exists in media
coverage of climate change
scientists constantly set forth
scenarios that often range from best
case to worst case
based on government policies or economic
growth for example
while trying to iron out all the kinks
of how our insanely complicated weather
system works
when these predictions are revised
people often criticize them for being
wrong
instead of lauding the scientists behind
them for doing their job
box wrote that since all models are
wrong the scientists must be alert to
what is
importantly wrong and whether you're
making advanced computer models or just
trying to give better advice
the steps are the same you predict see
the results and adjust the formula
and therein lies the problem with people
like crystal or whoever is giving you
pandemic hot takes on twitter there's no
iterative process there's no
accountability
as tetlock writes more often than not
forecasts are made
and then nothing accuracy is seldom
determined after the fact
every day the news media delivers
forecasts without reporting or even
asking
how good the forecasters who made the
forecast really are
so what should we do well for one avoid
tv
and maybe even youtube try to figure out
when people are predicting for sport
like on tv and if they have any
incentive at all to revise their bold
proclamations when they're incessantly
wrong
most people don't and i would predict
the world would be a much better place
if we listen to them
a little less frequently but what do i
know
what do you guys think how can we ever
know who to trust
let us know in the comments huge thanks
to our amazing patrons for your support
decimate that subscribe button and as
always thanks for watching guys
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you